abone ol
Herkese merhaba ben İsmail Şen olf
Halimden biraz daha yaşlı gördüğünüz e
20 yıldır bu sezon 20. sezonun spor
gazeteciliği yapıyorum xv sezonu maç
anlatıcılığı unda televizyonda sunuculuk
yapıyorum
spor yayıncılığı yanda mesleğim haline
geldi ve
hayatta Hem şu anda hayatımı geç
indiriyorum hem de bundan çok keyif
alıyorum genelde bana hep
daha genç
insanlar daha tutkulu sporu çok seven
insanlarla bir araya geldiğinde bana en
çok sorulan sorulardan birisi budur Ben
de ben de bu işi yapmak istiyorum Ben de
nasıl yapabilirim nasıl Nasıl oldu nasıl
spor spikeri olabilirim açıkçası
bunun en önemli cevabı ben nasıl oldum
diye düşündüm de ben genelde başaramadı
şey yapmadığım için oldu En büyük
hayalim
bir profesyonel sporcu olmaktı önce
katlettim sonra futbol oynadım amatör
kümede işte okul takımlarında basketbol
voleybol derken tek hayalim buydu
aslında hani hep başarı hikayelerinde
şunlar söylenir yani hayalkurun peşinden
gidin sonuna kadar inanın çalışın Ve
sonunda olacaktır Aslında Benimki pek
öyle olmadı ve genelde hikayeler de öyle
değildir önemli başarısızlıklar vardı Bu
işin içinde Benimki de ilk hayalini
kurduğum o profesyonel sporcu olmayı
başaramamak becerememek üzerinden oldu
peki Nasıl oldu da yanda hiç eğitimini
Almadım daha önce hiç bir şekilde
spor ya da İletişim ile alakalı bir okul
okumadan buraya bu pozisyona gelmiş
oldum Nasıl oldu da 20 senedir hala spor
gazeteciliği yapıyorum Aslında bu sonuç
yeni bir sürecin işi çok küçük
yaşlarımız dan itibaren Biz biz çok
sporu çok seven bir ailede büyüdüm bir
kere sürekli spor izliyorduk işte
atletizmden güreşe futboldan basketbola
her türlü spor branşını izliyorduk ve ve
spor hayatımızın bir parçası haline
gelmiş de eminim birçoğunuz için de aynı
aynı şey geçerlidir ve fark etmeden
bunun bir kişiyi şekillendirdiğini
gördüm hiç unutmuyorum 92 Olimpiyat
Oyunları çok küçüktüm o zaman da 8
yaşındayım ve ilk büyülendim basketbolun
ilk büyülendiği imandır Barselona da o
meşhur Dream Team işte Michael Jordan
Magic Johnson ve borç al bak yıkan
hepsini sayabilirsiniz o takımla beraber
öyle kanımıza yavaş yavaş o girmeye
başladı aynı zamanda spor yapıyoruz
antrenman larımız var Hafta sonu okulda
sürekli oynuyoruz sokakta sürekli
oynuyoruz eve gidiyoruz izliyoruz O da
yavaş yavaş işte konsollar çıktı
oynuyoruz Hayatımızın her yerinde spor
var 96 Olimpiyatları mesela hiç unutmam
yaz tatilinde ydik ve atlantıda
olimpiyat oyunları saat farkından dolayı
çok geç oluyordu önemli yarışlar Çünkü
oradaki saatte uydurmak için ve gece
kalkıp o zaman tatil deydik bir kamp
Kampta bir tatil deydik Babam ve
kardeşimle beraber gece kalkıp kampın
kafeteryasında ki televizyonu açıp ki
hatta o televizyonda böyle bir kafesin
içindeydi kafesinin arkasında
Parmaklıkların arkasından izlemek
durumunda kaldık erkekler 100 metre
finali Nida'nın belli kazanmıştı 200
metrede Michael Johnson vardı Bunların
hepsi bir anda benim için kahraman
haline geldi ve sporu yaşadık böyle bir
ailenin içinde yakasında ise eğitimin
devam ettiği anlaşıldı ki Ben
profesyonel sporcu olacak kadar
yetenekli değilim ya da bu farklı
eksiklerim var ve bu benim işim haline
gelmeyecek O esnada lisedeyken Tabii ki
hepinizin çok iyi bildiğimiz ve
üniversite sınavı hazırlıkları işte
mesleğin ne olacak Bununla ilgili
telaşlar derken o zaman lisedeki felsefe
öğretmenim ama çok güzel bir söz
söylemişti Platon'un bir sözüydü aracın
en üstündeki elmayı istiyorsan
gökyüzündeki yıldızlar Hedef diyeceksin
Peki çok etkileyici gelmişti Çünkü İşte
benim için bir hedef vardı ve o hedefi
en yukarıya getirmek istiyordum ve
kendimi olabilecek en iyi yere getirmek
istiyorum orada hedefim Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi'ni kazanmaktı ön kendime
böyle bir hedef koymuştur Hatta çalışma
masamın hemen karşısındaki duvara
Boğaziçi Üniversitesi posterini
koymuştum işte bildiğiniz bütün kişisel
gelişimcilerin uyguladığı o taktikler
hepsini uyguladım hedefi görselleştirme
sürekli söyledim kendime anlattım Evet
hocam bu olmalı benim için Boğaziçi var
başka bir hedef yok diye ve üzerinde çok
çalıştım İnanın bana çok çalıştım sonuna
kadar çalıştım ama Platon'un bilmediği
bir şey var
Boğaziçi olmadı ve ağacın en üstündeki
elmaya giderken ağaçtan düşmüş gibi oldu
çünkü o hedefe çok kilitlenmiş Team
Aslında iyi bir okulda yine Yeditepe
Üniversitesi'nde burslu bir şekilde
okumaya devam edecektir eğitim hayatına
devam edecektim ama olmadı dedim ya Yala
tonunda yanıldığı noktalar var diye
Aslında ağaca tırmanmanın keyfi ağacın
üstündeki elmayı yemekten çok daha fazla
Gideceğiniz yerin çok fazla bir önemi
yok esas önemli olan yolculuk Çünkü sizi
şekillendiren sizi farklı bir noktaya
getiren şey o yolculuktur Az önce İyi
çok güzel bir konuşma yaptı orada kendi
konuşmasında kendi yolculuğundan
bahsetti hiç Hedef olmadan bir anda
Moskova gitmesi ve Ben buradan çıkış
yapması Gerçekten de öyle kişiyi
şekillendiren şey bu yolculuk oluyor
yolculuğun sonunda farklı bir yere
varmış oluyorsunuz 20 Senem 20 sene
öncesine dönüp baktığımda ya da 30 sene
öncesine gidelim daha küçük bundan da
küçük olan İsmail bunu söylediğinizde
bunu Hayal edemezdi O yüzden bazen hayal
etmek kendinizi sınırlayabilir bazen
Bazen hayal etmeden sadece yolculuğun
içinde olmak ve kendi doğrularımızı
kendi hayatınızı en iyi şekilde yaşamak
en doğrusu Olabilir Neden biliyor
musunuz Çünkü hedefe ulaştığınızda
aslında ya da o elmayı yediğinizde
Aslında her zaman
Beklediğiniz şey olmayabiliyor 2012
Euroleague final hatırlar mısınız Sinan
Erdem Spor Salonu'nda ydı Ç SSK Moskova
ile Olympiakos oynuyorduk CSKA Moskova
Euroleague tarihinin Bence en iyi 2 3
kadrosundan birisiydi oyun kurucu bu
odası iç işler ama nasıl şiş kouskous
Android Linux Emre'den dönmüş hala çok
iyi en verimli olduğu dönemlerden birisi
Viktor khryapa var nenad krstic var
kenardan cama vurdum geliyor inanılmaz
bir kadro gerçekten ve herkes o 4 takım
oraya geldiğinde İstanbul'da CSKA
Moskova'nın şampiyon olacağından emindi
gerçekten Emin de karşısındaki olimpiyat
konuştu işte bir tane yıldız oyuncusu
var Evet vassilis spanoulis ama
diğerleri çoğunlukla genç oyuncular iki
tane tecrübeli Yunan oyuncusu daha var
Ama çoğunlukla gençlerden oluşan ve
sadece finalde olmaktan mutlu bir takım
var
Olympiakos gerçekten tam da beklendiği
gibi ç s k karşısında üçüncü çeyreğin
sonuna doğru 19 sayı geriye düşmüştü her
şey tahmin edildiği gibi oluyordu ve o
esnada olimpiyakosun
benchten yedek kulübesinden birisi çıkıp
kulübe değil tabi yeşil kenardan birisi
kalkıp Milan tomiç eski bir oyuncu kendi
sik ben duşa nilco içe gidip şunu
söyledin Koç
çarşamba günü Lig maçımız var
Panathinaikos da beraber zaten bu maçta
bitti yani içeri zeka gibi bir de ve
zaten 20s gerideyiz
İstersen Hani biraz yıldızları
dinlendirelim gençlerle devam edelim ne
dersin ilk konuştu Evet çok güzel fikir
deyip sonrasında gençleri soktu ve bir
anda bir üçlük 2 3 lük derken son
çeyreğe 12 sayı farkla geride girdiler
19/12 indirdiler son çeyreğin ilk
pozisyonunda da bir üçlük geldi mi dokuz
sayıya indi ki basketbol oynayanların
çok iyi bilir farkın tek hanelere inmesi
önemli bir psikolojik eşittir 9 sayı
indikten sonra olmayacak şeyler oldu
belki Euro Lig tarihinin gelmiş geçmiş
en iyi serbest satıcısı şiş kavgaz çok
önemli farelerden yararlanamadı ve
Android kirilenko işte O bahsettiğim
Belki o anda Avrupa'nın en iyi
oyuncusuydu Android girilen ve kendisine
çok güvendiği için belki o güvenin biraz
ki bir sınırına geçtiği için yapmaması
gereken bir yardım savunması yaptı
Vasilis panavise karşı arkada printezis
unutmuştu printezis bomboş basketi attı
son saniye ve Olympiakos o maçta ilk kez
öne geçti Olympiakos Avrupa şampiyonu
oldu tarihe yazılacak hayatları boyunca
ki 15 sene sonra oldular 15 sene önce de
Koç duşa ninkovic Tea hayatları boyunca
bir daha yaşamaları belki mümkün olmayan
inanılmaz bir şampiyonluk to
olimpiyakosun ki Dış anichkov İç sahada
işte 2 3 zıpladı lar 3-4 dakika geçti
hemen Flash interwire derler hemen Maç
biter bitmez orada ilk röportajı vermek
zorundadır antrenör daha kupa törenine
madalya törenine geçilmeden oraya
gittiğinde söylediği bir şey vardı Koç
nasıl hissediyorsunuz diye sordu biz de
geleceğiz resmi yayıncı biziz röportajı
O ne yapıyor Ben de çeviriyorum o anda
Şok olmuştum gerçekten hayatta bunun
Bana en çok
vurduğu nokta olabilir bu fikrin Bana en
çok vurdu Nokta olabilir duşa ninkovic
şunu söyledi
iyi bakın dene Az önce olduğumdan daha
mutsuz hissediyorum çünkü bütün sezon
yaptığınız bütün çalışma yaptı
verdiğiniz bütün Emek Az önceki
mutluluğu yaşamak için de sadece Ceo
mutluluk dediği otuz saniye bir dakika
Belki belki çok daha büyük bir rahatlık
hissediyordum mutluluktan çok yani
ağacın tepesine çıktığında yediği elma
ama evet güzel Ama hayatımda sadece bir
andan ibaret Halbuki diğer yolculuk duşa
ninkovic ean koviç gibileri
olimpiyakosun hikayesini özel kılıyor
İşte diğer yolculuk zaten anlattığımız
ve üzerinde durduğumuz en önemli şey
yolculuğa odaklanmak gideceğiniz yere
değil Bunu yaparken de bilinçli bir
özgüvene sahip olmak çok kıymetli yani
bilinçli Özgüven ne demek bir kere ne
yapacağını bilmek çok önemli ikincisi ne
yapmak istediği bu çok önemli İkincisi
nasıl yapacağını bilmek çok önemli
üçüncüsü ne zaman yapacağını bilmek çok
önemli ki inanın ben bu zamanlama
konusunda
sabır konusunda çok iyi değilimdir en
zorlandığım noktalardan birisiydi ne
zaman yapacağını bilmek çok önemli hangi
şekilde davranacağını bilmek çok önemli
kendini tanıyabilmek önemli bu soruları
kendinize her sorduğunuzda kendinize
emniyete almış oluyorsunuz Çünkü bazen o
yolculuk sizi farklı yerlere götürüyor
Bazen o yolculuğun içinde bir şeye
kapılıyorsunuz yakaladığınız bir başarı
olabilir başarısızlık olabilir Çok kötü
bir maç kaybetmiş olabilirsiniz ya da
bir sınavınız çok kötü geçmiş olabilir
Yada iş yerindeyken patronunuza bir
sorun yaşamışsınız dır ya da hasılat
kötü gelmiştir ve önemli sorunlar
yaşıyor olabilirsiniz ama o yolculuğu
güzel kılan şey budur ve bu burada
yaşadığınız Oo Ya bunlar o başarılar çok
yüksek başarı yada çok düşük
başarısızlık anlarında Az önceki
soruları kendinize sormanız kendinizi
emniyete almanızı sağlar bilinçli bir
özgüvene sahip olmak Ben ne yapıyorum ne
yapmak istiyorum Nasıl yapmam gerekiyor
ve ne zaman yapmalıyım Hangi zamanlama
da yapmalıyım bu en önemli en önemli
işlerden birisidir Çünkü o yolculukta
savrulmak çok daha kolay bu savrulmayı
engelleyebilir en kritik nokta Bence bu
Peki
neden bu önemli çünkü Eğer bu bu
soruları kendine sormazsan Eğer bu
soruları sen cevapla mazsan Eğer sürekli
yanında bu sorular senin işte
merdivenden çıkarken bir trabzanın
olmazsa bu soruları başkası cevaplamak
durumunda kalır bu soruları sana başkası
sorduğunda başkası cevapladığın da
başkasının cevaplarını verdiğinde o İyi
o zaman kendin olmaktan
uzaklaşabilir sin o zaman farklı bir
yolculuğa gidebilirsin O yüzden kendinle
ilgili bilinçli bir özgüvene sahip olmak
daha gerçek gerçek olmak kendine karşıtı
çok kıymetli bir mesela evden alırsın
NBA tarihinin gelmiş geçmiş en yetenekli
oyuncularından birisi en büyük skor
yerlerinden birisi olabilir sorsanız bir
röportajında O şunu söylüyor hep ben ben
Kobe Bryant gibi değildim KOBİ başka bir
yaratıktı başka bir varlıktı diyor Evet
yaratık diye bahsediyor kobiden
Biz gece kulüplerine giderdik eğlenirdik
KOBİ o sırada antrenmanda olurdu ama
aramızda ki şampiyonluk yüzüklerini
ve Aramızdaki şampiyonluk yüzükleri de
bu sayede oldu zaten Belki daha eversin
Kombiden daha yetenekliydi bilmiyoruz
olabilir sadece yetenek kıyaslarsak ama
aradaki farkı kendisini iyi de bu arada
ayvırsın seçimi olmadığını söyleyemeyiz
O da o kendi tercihini bu şekilde yaptım
ve farklı bir figür olarak hala anılıyor
onu da kötü bir yol olduğunu
söyleyemeyiz Ama eğer söz konusu takım
başarısı ve kariyer s basketbol kariyeri
ise kol İbrahim çok daha fazla çok daha
üst noktada olduğunu
biliyoruz kris başvuru çok güzel anlatır
basketbol şöhretler müzesine girdiğinde
yaptığı bir konuşma vardır ve o
konuşmada kris başvuru çok güzel anlatır
Ben ben Amerikan milli takımına
seçildiğinde Dream Team in bir üyesi
olarak kendime herkese ispatlamak
istemiştim Kobe bryant'ın ne kadar çok
çalıştığını biliyordum ve ilk işim Sabah
ilk antrenmanı yapan kişi olmaktı Bunu
daha ilk idmandan herkese gösterecektim
ve herkese o mesajı vermek istiyordum
diyor kris var Sabah altı buçukta
kalkıyor aşağıya iniyor tam antrenmana
gidecek o sırada Kobe Bryant kahva ne
yapıyor Sırılsıklam terli tişörtünü
antrenmanı bitirmiş ve kahvaltısını
yapıyor aslında KOBİ yapan ya da özel
yapan şey bu o da kendisini bilip
kendisiyle alakalı doğruları en iyi
şekilde uygulayan kişi Peki Hem bu
sadece kendinizi doğru Bilmek önemli bu
nasıl olur
bir pritchard bir insanın başarısıyla
ilgili
bi en önemli faktörün genler olduğunu
söyler ama o genlerinde yüzde yirmi beş
etkene sahip olduğunu söyler
bir insanın başarısında genler yüzde
yirmi beş annenizden babanızdan gelen
sizi siz yapan genler yüzde yirmi beş
farklı Peki yüzde yetmiş beş Ne o da
çevresel faktörler hangi çevrede
Bulunduğunuz kimlerle oynadığınız
kimlerle konuştuğunuz kimlerle birlikte
olduğunuz nasıl şartlarda yetiştiniz
sizi siz yapan başarılı ya da başarısız
yapan ya da göreceli olarak hayatınızda
gitmek istediğiniz yolla koyan şey
çevresel faktörler oluyor aslında 125'li
yüzde yetmiş beş çok daha büyük çok daha
farklı a Örneğin Skype'ın Skyfall çok
çocuklu bir ailede yetişme Çok fakir ve
küçük bir kasabada büyüme
bir basketbolcu biliyorsunuz 90'larda
Efsanesi kabusta Michael Jordan da
beraber altı şampiyonluk yaşamış bir
isim büyürken
Toprak sahada basketbol oynuyor şimdi
diyorsunuz ki işte yani Bir insan bu
kadar uzun boylu ve ya bu kadar iyi
topart niyetine sahip olabiliyor işte
Toprak sahada oynayınca topun nereye
gideceğini kontrol edemiyorsunuz Tabii
ki öyle olunca top hakimiyeti niz çok
daha gelişiyor ve Skype'ın oluyorsunuz
Belki oradaki Toprak sahalar Skype'ın
Skype'ın yaptı bazen şartlardan şikayet
etmek çok kolay olabilir Ama o şartların
doğru yolculukta kendinize doğru
soruları sorduğunda o bilinçli özgüveni
uyguladığınızda sizi getireceği yer
dünyanın tepesi de olabilir Skype'dan
için öyle oldu çevresel faktörleri doğru
planlayabilmek sizin elinizde
genlerinizi pil anlayamazsınız onları
annenizden babanızdan gelen miraslar Ama
bu Bu bir odaya girdiğinizde hep hep bir
şey sözü vardır ya eğer Bulunduğunuz
odadaki en zeki kişi Sizsiniz
belki odayı değiştirmeniz gerekiyor
belki doğru O da değilsiniz dir diye
konfüçyüs'e atfedilen bir sözdür Bu bir
taraftan da odadaki herkesten hala bir
şey öğrenebilirsiniz Ben şu anda iki
buçuk yaşındaki oğlundan ve Bir
yaşındaki kızından çok şeyler
öğreniyorum hala daha öğreniyorum en
zeki olmak odadaki en zeki olmak sizi
daha ileri götürmeye Bilir Ya da daha
yavaş götürebilir doğru sürekli
Çevrenizi geliştirmek o yüzde yetmiş
beşe daha çok yarayabilir Bu da doğru
ama bazen de
odada farklı kişilerden de farklı şeyler
öğrenebilirsiniz Bu yüzden Çevrenizi
doğru kullanmanız gerekiyor Bu yüzden
şartlarınız başaramadıklarını zın sizi
belirlemesine İzin vermeyin Ben Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi'ni
98 yılında üniversite sınavına girmiştim
2002'de geldim özür dilerim 2002'de Hı
hı Üniversitesi kazanamadım ama Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi'nin kapısından ilk kez 2016
yılında girdim oda yılın spor spikeri
Ödülünü almak için oldu hayatın böyle
güzel oyunları oluyor ve
ya o yüzden hedefinizden çok yolculuğa
odaklanmanız gerekiyor ve iyi bir
yolculuk sizi olabileceğiniz en iyi kişi
yapabilir her zaman bu yüzden
Gideceğiniz yerden çok yolculuğu
odaklanmanızı bilirim sevgiler
abone ol